qué es lo que está llevando al aumento
de los secuestros en el país y si tiene
un tinte político esta problemática
es una cosa muy complicada porque al
final del año observamos
casos de secuestro pero esta vez son
muchos desde el fin de 2020 y al inicio
de este año
constatamos que hay muchos muchos casos
de
de secuestros
varias informaciones salieron de las
organizaciones de defensa de derechos
humanos para acercar a la criminalidad
con
en múltiplos políticos y casi siempre
con una relación con el gobierno y está
en el poder ahora es por eso que dicen
que estos casos de supuestos tienen un
sentido político si ahora el segundo
punto es el mandato del presidente de
las elecciones de 2015 fueron anuladas
por denuncias de fraude y repetidas en
moix asumió en 2017 para un período de
cinco años pero la oposición argumenta
que son cuatro años porque se adelantó
el inicio del periodo presidencial
cuando termina realmente el mandato del
presidente
la constitución de haití dice que cuando
las elecciones se retrasan el mandato
vivencial empieza el año de las
elecciones el año de las elecciones fue
2016 y entonces a pesar de que el
presidente empezó su mandato como tal
toma función en 2010 17 su mandato es
reputado
haber empezado desde el 7 febrero de
2016 es por esto basándose sobre la
constitución dicen que el mandato
presidencial va a terminarse el 7 de
febrero del 2021 y sobre eso también hay
un aviso que es un aviso de todos todas
las mesas de abogados en el país que
dice la misma cosa ahora el señor pies
cuáles son los puntos que plantea la
posición para pedir la renuncia de moix
y realmente no piden ahora
la renuncia de mi móvil y porque antes
durante los meses antes le pidieron la
renuncia de los mármoles pero ahora
abogan para que respeta la ley respeta
la constitución la constitución dicen es
el mismo documento para todo el mundo y
yo en el mois el mismo y aplicó la ley
de la constitución para reducir de un
año dos años los contactos de los
senadores de diez senadores al inicio de
ahora piden que los de louis aplica la
misma ley para el mismo